ó ó energia dos riscos a que ser feliz
nós podemos ter influência
então não errou uma pessoa podia se
queixar que não pode entrar no curso
certo porque o pai não deixou porque a
vida não tem a oportunidade de emprego
ou porque enfim as pessoas nos silva
lembra filoso poder fazer isso todos os
dias ficamos comportamos como servida
nos devia alguma coisa nós sim somos
seres especiais para a nossa vida
deveria ser justa e ficamos nessa
atitude mas se nós tivéssemos o trato e
tudo e pensar se o que que eu evite
ficar à espera do quê vida tem de melhor
para mim eu se disse que o queria dar o
quê que eu posso dar melhor a vida e o
que eu posso me adaptar melhor a vida é
o meu sorriso é que o que eu faço é
fácil rir é quando sorriu que às vezes
acaba rir
em resposta inovadora para poder criar
uma vida nova é que a atividade que o
faço com o tempo para o tempo voa em vez
daquelas atividades que eu faço que você
passa espera que acaba espera que acaba
semana para finalmente virou fins na
nokia a cabo o ano letivo finalmente pra
poder ter umas férias naquela cidade em
que sou eu mesma em que eu mostre não
tem vergonha de mostrar o meu talento
é o momento em que é quanto essa vida e
essa razão para que nós estamos aqui e
viver era para podermos viver realmente
os nossos talentos
quem salva o seu talento
por que não seguir em frente com ela
agora eventualmente quina platéias ter
alguém a dizer assim
poxa eu não fui mas não tenho perfil de
paciente em segundo e nem sequer conhece
nenhum talento
não tenha não só desses privilegiados
mas todos nós temos um talento e muitas
vezes e nos piores momentos da nossa
vida que nós nos descobrimos é sentido
como um ovo é num momento de desespero
sentir que está a asfixiar com o pinto
no seu desespero quebra é casca e nash e
muitas vezes nós temos essas
instituições e uma das muitas histórias
que se podia contar que os problemas de
saúde que entrou nos profissionais
vou partilhar aqui escrevi uma história
médica dentista uma clínica uma
sociedade obviamente problemas na
sociedade é matemática é um problema que
estavam a colocar na iminência de não
poder ir retirar dinheiro à imprensa
e como você imagina o cmdm ameaçada por
médico dentista não é bem como advogado
na época tanto pode ser comentador
político como comentador de futebol
enfim uma é uma cidade permite fazer
várias coisas mas uma rede tem dentista
especialista em ortodontia que não pode
fazer absolutamente mais nada pra poder
me ver e eu comecei a pensar se eu não
pudesse retirar com a imprensa como é
que eu ia viver como é que eu ia
alimentar homofilia que num momento
dramático da minha vida e eu pensei o
que une as realidades faça um faça
sorrir que adora fazer e lembrando que o
durava para criar o meu conhecimento que
os meus alunos nessa altura não queria
que o tempo para a segurava como
professor universitário e transmitir
conhecimento inspirar e lembrando que
havia alunos mesmo dias a professora
então quando encontrava aquela palavra
condição uns anos atrás modificou a
minha vida eu mudei de curso ou eu fui
por todo dia por sua causa e eu pensei
por que não montar um curso clínico
curso que eu gostava de freqüentar
enquanto aluna é que o curso em que
realmente podia partilhar tudo aquilo
que seria e assim foi
seis meses depois eu tinha seis mil
quinhentos e e positivos 290 essas
citações bibliográficas e mantém um
curso clínico que eu gostaria de ter
tido enquanto aluno
acesso dizemos há 13 anos durante 11
anos
nós temos que mexer eo gana o que uma
fonte de rendimento adicional para além
da minha fonte de rendimento habitual
clínica
então esse exatamente no momento que o
descobriu um talento e uma tímida em que
estava porque a aplicação tópica nervosa
mas eu tenho uma certa timidez lidar com
as pessoas mas essa força de vontade que
contenham avançasse
então o que aconteceu eu utilizei este
sorriso como os hits transformador e eu
sorrio e tornam se lixe um sorriso em
que não tem problemas em expor a minha
essência em mostrar a minha força e
dizer eu sou isto claro que eu posso
conquistar alguns jogos
eventualmente algumas invejas acredito
mas também por ser libertadora porque
outras pessoas possam sentir vontade
também de se libertar e mostrará em todo
o seu potencial e é nesse momento que
nós podemos fazer a diferença em que
expulsamos os ladrões sorrisos e vivemos
na vida não uma vida mais somente de uma
pinguinha de vinho ou um cafezinho nós
vivemos tudo a que temos direito
fish e ciência é que quando nós rimos
nós estamos a desenvolver a nossa mente
deve siga um psiquiatra neurocientista
eu disse que nós desenvolvemos a mente
quando estamos temos relações
interpessoais bárbara fredrickson
psicóloga tem um trabalho brilhante na
área da neurociência e diz que quando
nós rimos com a festa mesmo que seja
para um desconhecido nós estamos a
libertar da mina e expor a ativação do
para simpático está a tornar nos mais
serenos mais calmos baixando assim com
cardíaco portanto sugiro lhe traz pra
ficar mais calmo enfrentadas contra
outros risos
acontece que nós não conseguimos pensar
quantos nos sentimos ameaçados alstom os
termos de obtenção e não conseguimos dar
o nosso melhor senhora chegaram onde a
se mandar pegar vocês pelos pés e dizia
assim olha para fazer uma continha
simples pinto
3 que ela não conseguimos não
conseguimos usar a nossa parte cognitiva
enquanto a parte emocional não se
gastava prestigiar o amigo voz nervoso
primais riam adorassem e só depois é que
venham com as explicações lógicas senão
ela de novo então é só apenas alguns
exemplos de investigações científicas
que são importantes que os resolvi
escrever um livro numa linguagem comum
para explicar aos meus pacientes eles
queriam ter um sorriso bonito não podia
chegar a permitir tudo lhes desse um
sorriso bonito eu podia fazer a parte
física eu estava nas mãos de deus
construir o sorriso em que devia com as
suas escolhas para que só alguns
aspectos das medalhas disse nós estamos
a sorrir cada vez menos e fomos fortes
parceiros
os preços no mês passado diz que nós
temos que baixar o nosso que estamos
cada vez no mais tecnológico que apesar
disso estamos com que mais baixa
nós tivemos também pela na ciência e
recomendo é me cure
ela fez a importância das nossas
expressões não verbais para comandar
aquilo que nós pensamos sentimos os meus
pensamentos quando eu ando assim as
minhas escolhas eventualmente serão
diferentes quando eu ando assim então
quer dizer que quando eu sorrio e
contacto com as pessoas e come com elas
com afeto com este sorriso eu escolhi a
minha mente eu tô mudar os meus
resultados
então ter esta coxinha se é de que eu
posso andar na vida com um sorriso
escolher um fácil rir revela a sabedoria
e da minha responsabilidade no sentido
de culpa mas no sentido de uma
habilidade de uma nova resposta para
comandar e ser líder da minha vida
isso quer dizer que vou andar sempre a
sorrir e pateta alegre não quer dizer
que eu vou ter outra perspectiva sobre
as coisas eu vou viver a vida com
os olhos mas alex com os olhos mais
afetuosos e vou encontrar novas soluções
as inscrições podem ser as mesmas mexi
eu dou-lhes um embrulho de frente e
minha vida passa a ser muito diferente
ponto 2
sabendo o que sabemos tem que fazer algo
para ter uma vida diferente
não adianta é uma emoção que não
funciona para os mesmos resultados
os problemas vão sempre existir o que
interessa é que nós vamos fazer
comentários
então o que o proponho como
transformação da sociedade contagiar
contagiar com o prédio que compreende
como é que comprar e sentir que nós
chamamos todos estamos todos ligados
porque o amor e energia mais pura da
vitalidade a cada célula que compõem te
dá ato e que nos unir tudo que existe
com esta perspectiva nós não precisamos
competir porque o nosso risco individual
depende do sorriso coletivo que vai
afetar os nossos rios individual por
isso e não é por acaso que estamos no
painel do cantor dinho quer discutir a
porque nós temos esta capacidade de
influenciar as pessoas que estão à nossa
volta e de mudar uma sociedade cada um
sabe como quer contagiar eu queria
intervir na educação eu sei que foram
enxergadas pressão nós podemos cantar
gera a nossa sociedade para uma
sociedade mais de 80 nós já vimos
conjunto filosofia da cultura industrial
em pinhais as crianças numa escola para
poderem ir trabalhar e ir lá treinava as
crianças para poderem ser o velhas para
poderem vir ser bons operários fazerem
regras cumprirem ordens e andarem atrás
da senhora dos resultados na situação de
ser um espaço para nós podermos formar
líderes líderes que sejam 14 a sua
história e que desenvolveu então uma
cultura de sorriso
então nessa dimensão eu criei uma
ferramenta que é um projeto social que
se chama se my own dança na prática é um
micro musical tem uma história
somente mas pensava em que estágio da
história quanto uma parte da história e
que tem como objetivo vivenciar os
conteúdos sejam lentos matemática sem
chão e ao chile fia os estados físicos
da água ou hábito rotina como escovar os
dentes é uma forma divertida de aprender
porque nós aprendemos mais quando nos
divertimos
nós aprendemos mais quando nos contam
histórias e nós aprendemos mais com quem
nós que estamos que estarão nos sentimos
bem então com estas com estes princípios
de neurociência de uma forma lúdica como
se fosse um filme para dar o comprimido
o cão
nós criamos uma ferramenta que fizemos
formação acreditada professores para os
poderem fazer em sala de aula
e aí podemos ensinar inclusivamente as
crianças serem mais afetuosas mais
furiosas porque se nós queremos uma
sociedade com menos de bullying
criamos uma sociedade onde as pessoas
perdem
nós temos não que elas fossem esses
problemas porque senão é como se eu
dissesse que a hora não pensei um fã de
samuels né eu quero é que nós nos
focamos nas girafas então aproximar as
crianças e fazê lo se apaixonar pelo
conhecimento e fazer com que a escola se
chama de tia may meio hoje aprendi uma
coisa nova foi lançar esse risco nós
aprendemos então tem estado a formar
professores e técnicos seu uso como esta
ferramenta não é um flash mob
nós queremos respeitar a diferença tendo
um movimenta o corpo como acha que deve
expressar e do conteúdo
nós conseguimos passar conteúdos
abstratos como matemática mas também
conseguimos expressar o nosso corpo como
expressamos nossos talentos os nossos
medos como é que podemos fazer amigos só
gerir conflitos comprar e acima de tudo
sobrar e temos ótimos fedex das crianças
por exemplo e agora não há espaço para
muito mas eu podia dizer vos que este
foi o início mas muito corrente segmento
as crianças gritavam
amigo da minha turma e agora é gravar
essas maldades já não acontece isto é
tão bom e é tão importante contributo
porque que efetivamente nós temos é
cultivar uma cultura de sorriso
o terceiro ponto esta palestra singrar
nós já podemos rir com o que temos nós
temos tantas coisas pelas quais nós
podemos sorrir então saber valorizar e
sentir gratidão e realmente fundamental
se queremos ter mais velocidade mais
saúde e mais cessa por ser bem sucedido
não é ter o carro x ou y
mas eventualmente é poder acordar todos
os dias isso ricos nossos inimigos
ok então pode terminar eu queria propor
também aqui e não só na escola
chegamos a falar sobre três com sites eu
queria que vocês os levassem de uma
forma de vivenciar vida e como através
de uma falha dança posso contar com o
vosso apoio
então vá primeiro conceito é fácil
transmitir tanta informação num curto
espaço de tempo
então o passado aqui em primeiro com o
site podemos sorrir com os olhos
amorosos para as pessoas que estão à
nossa volta por libertar endorfinas
este é o primeiro conteúdo que eu falei
hoje segundo conteúdo para transformar
nós precisamos trabalhar em pressão
então precisamos de todos na mesma
direção ao terceiro andar mané se
lembrar não precisamos agir nos diga que
você achou fantástico que nós podemos
ter essa voz dentro nós cristina pa 31
máximo neve está e sair com essa energia
então vamos nos levantar
eu vou dizer os gestos dos gestos
este aqui é uma coisa rápida porque é
formação nós damos aos professores que
uma formação acreditava e 25 horas
portanto vocês aqui tão cedo mesmo é ser
mesmo muito longe de fazer estrago então
é assim cada um faz o seu gesto é que
não crie flash mobs uma sociedade de
carneirada não queremos queremos uma
sociedade em que te deum élcio ser única
e se respeita
pra mim o maior sorriso do mundo é assim
e quando eu faço isto melhor sorriso
mundo vocês devolvem o que é que o vosso
melhor sorriso muito cada um faz com que
quer mas talvez surja um cartaz que
inclui então vá eu sou rei com esse
sorriso do mundo a otan no eu vou dizer
eu adoro os que os risos nós e o plano
que cada um faz o seu
ok sua entrada a segunda música segundo
estágio comprar pra mim procurar a
significa que eu vou divertir na última
semente é tal que temos aqui todos na
mesma direção quando faz um gesto de
dizer eu estou na mesma direção
vai-te técnica volta votar projetos você
chama iniciais 30 estágio que eu dou uns
lembra como quero
ok daí que sobrar
gaete silva a mesma ser e vai vai entrar
a música
portanto nós estamos aqui a fazer é
condicionar vos com o flex pavor
associará illuzzi cá um conceito teórico
um movimento pra eu ter a certeza que
daqui um ano ainda se lembrou desta
palestra olharmos
eu choro não
ae
obrigada contagiem todo mundo esteja
vossa volta o vosso isso obrigado
ó ó